Relational databases always have a schema. What is
a schema? In layman's terms a schema is
a blueprint that tells the database how we
plan to store our data. More specifically, a schema
basically says that for a given table, every
single row or entry will have the exact same
number of columns that correspond to the same
values and that each column's value will be formatted
in the same way. So, for example, in this table, I can say that there are
four columns: district name, capital city, size, and
population. District name and capital city might always be
strings, where size might be a float, and
population might be an int. This list of columns
and their requirements on how their values are
formatted define the schema for this table. Now let's
add some entries to the table. Let's say
the first [UNKNOWN] I wish to enter is corresponds
to the district Gujarat which has 60,439,692 people,
has an area of 196,024 square kilometers and has
a capital city of Gandhinagar. All of these
entries fit the schema, so inserting this row into
the table is fine. Now, let's say I
had another I wish to add, the Maharashtra district,
which has a capital city of Mumbai, and I provide no
other values. This would also be allowed, but for all columns for
which I don't specify values, the value would either be set
to null or default values that are stored in the table definition.